my name is Iman blow from Brooklyn New
York
I am a senior now at Columbia College
studying biology and I'm on the women's
fencing team
I started fencing because my brother's
camp friends told us about a program
called the Peter Westbrook foundation in
New York City and I have a twin brother
and the head of the program Peter
Westbrook said that we had potential and
so we started the program together
my brother quit after a month my dad
told me I had to keep going and then I
started fencing then until now and it's
really that program that actually led me
to Columbia
I started off losing three out of my
first seven matches and last season I
only lost three matches when I won my
individual title and at that moment I
realized that not only was my own
individual success at whist but I might
jeopardize this victory for the team
after that I only lost one more match
and I remember I actually won the match
that clinched the title my next goal is
the Olympic Trials I actually leave next
Wednesday for the first Olympic trial in
Tarboro Bishop star in Germany
interestingly enough I have my second
Olympic qualifier in Shanghai and I get
back at 6:00 p.m. the day before I
graduate